Morris Berman is a visiting professor in
sociology at the Catholic University of
America in Washington DC
visit Morris Berman dot blog spot.com
for more information
radical innocent is Anthony Arthur's new
biography of Upton Sinclair during this
45 minute talk learn about st. Clare's
1906 muckraking novel the jungle his
campaign for California Governor in the
early 1930s and his late career as a
historical novelist thank you Jeff good
afternoon everyone
the best Sheppard Morrison CLS C fund an
endowment held in the Chautauqua
Foundation provides funding for this
afternoon's presentation and as you know
additional support for this entire
week's program is provided by the
Lincoln family applied ethics program
collaboration between Chautauqua and
David and Joan Lincoln and their family
[Applause]
two years ago Tony Arthur approached
Chautauqua and planted the seed for the
theme of this week the obligations of
citizenship based on his scholarship of
Upton Sinclair Toni thought the social
conscience of a journalist could be the
basis for a week's worth of discussion
we thought so too and expanded on his
original idea to include such topics as
philanthropy the history of civics and
the opportunity to serve in public
office we are very pleased that Tony is
here with us this week and a meekley
please his entire family has joined him
for an extended Chautauqua vacation he
is here today to read from his new
biography of Upton Sinclair Radical
innocent the book was recently published
by Random House to mark the 100th
anniversary of Sinclair's seminal work
the jungle a novel that continues to
stand is one of the most important works
in the literature of social change Tony
has taught American literature at
California State University Northridge
in various times throughout his academic
career he was a Fulbright Scholar and
hungry exchange professor in Germany and
a visiting professor at the US Air Force
Academy ladies and gentlemen please join
me in a warm welcome for Tony Sinclair
thank you Jeff and Jeff I have indeed
been here for many years my wife Carolyn
who was Carolyn Taylor of Erie
introduced me to Chautauqua back in the
60s and we have come here not every year
because we moved to Los Angeles in 1970
but maybe eight or ten times over the
years trekking across country driving
sometimes as our kids are fond of
reminding us and a Volkswagen bus was no
air conditioning that shows our
dedication our son learned to play sail
here and I played tennis a lot with Jeff
getting beaten and by his father who
also beat me but I don't hold a grudge I
can't tell you how pleased I am to be
here on the podium having attended so
many of these lectures myself and seeing
so many wonderful speakers like Hannes
Johnson yesterday at mr. Saltzburg er
this morning it's and Mark Russell will
be here this evening I mean that's a
great it's a great privilege to be in
such good company but Chautauqua does
treat its writers write even Sinclair
was here 71 years ago 1935 in July now
this was the year after he had run for
governor of California and he was on the
amphitheater stage on a Saturday
afternoon a little different procedure
at that time with a conservative
congressman from New York State Hamilton
fish Sinclair had a lot of good fun with
that name he left a record what they
were talking about was the
constitutionality of Sinclair's program
for ending poverty in California which
was very complicated but a revolutionary
plan that he hoped to put in if he had
been elected governor that didn't happen
as we'll talk about but it was close
enough to worry a lot of people and and
strenuous enough that Sinclair had some
campaign debts to pay off afterwards and
that was
of why he was here at Chautauqua he
regarded himself to a degree as being in
the camp of the enemy and he left behind
a record one of the nice things about
Sinclair but also a bit intimidating for
a biographer as he wrote down everything
that ever happened to him and he lived
90 years and a lot of things happen but
one of the things that he remarked about
Chautauqua was kind of an amusing
observation he said he looked around and
he saw mostly white haired ladies and
church deacons who come to enjoy the
cool breezes from the lake and have
their minds entertained by high-class
vaudeville hey see he said he was he was
strolling on the brick walks the shady
brick walks and he overheard the ladies
debating he said shall they take in the
Sinclair fish show or shall they play
bridge this afternoon and wait and I
love this thing for the Swiss yodelers
and the Belgian bell ringers in the
email well Sinclair obviously had no
high preconceived notion of the quality
of his audience nor of his opponent who
he said was amiable but stupid beyond
belief and we might well expect that his
speech would have been a disaster
but in fact according to the report in
The Daily and I'm grateful to mr.
Schmidt's of the archives for digging up
this information it went off quite well
Sinclair was always quite good on the
stage on the platform for a
self-described introvert and though he
was often very tart in print and person
he had a kind of southern court lateness
he was born in Baltimore of southern
parentage and always kept that manner
about him throughout his long life
Charlie Chaplin who was a good friend of
his said that he always spoke through a
smile
so he knew how to exercise that charm
when he chose to and apparently he did
on this day he was pleasantly surprised
by the receptiveness of the Chautauqua
audience which even gave him the famous
hanky salute which he thought was really
quite lovely the report the debate that
he had was important enough to be noted
in the New York Times and in his old
enemies the Los Angeles Times but more
about that perhaps later and of course
the daily gave it very full coverage
there's every reason I think why
Sinclair should have felt at home here
and I think ultimately he did because he
really spoke fondly of the place the
theme for this week as we know is
applied ethics and the responsibilities
of citizenship but it's also been one of
Chautauqua's themes throughout its
history which is why it's so appropriate
but what's interesting for me at least
and perhaps for you is that I believe
she talked was start they said at 1874
and Sinclair's start date he was born in
1878
so his lifetime roughly coincides with
the earlier three quarters of
Chautauqua's lifetime alike Chautauqua
Sinclair was and remains a kind of
unique force and presence in American
history and life and I think I can talk
about that in roughly three different
ways this was very hard for me to do I
know you don't care how hard that was
but
he lived 90 years and he did an awful
lot a lot of writers spend that time in
their rooms typing and drinking but
Sinclair just did the typing part and he
was out of his room a lot doing many
many things so I've tried to schedule my
talk today to leave a little time for
questions because I know many of you are
going to say why didn't he talk about
that or that and I want to give you the
chance to do that so I've just focused
on three things that make him I think a
unique figure in American literary and
social history and you probably can
guess that the first of those is of
course the research and the writing and
the promotion which is important of the
jungle in and around 1906 of the second
you can also guess as his campaign for
governor in 1933 and 1934 and the third
which will be familiar to some of you
especially the older members of the
audience is that magnificent series of
books he wrote called the Lani Budd
books beginning in 1938 and not ending
until 1953 he effectively reinvented
himself beginning at the age of 60 as a
historical novelist and for me in some
ways that's the most fascinating aspect
of his life although it's the one that I
will spend the least amount of time on
just because of limitations of time
starting with the jungle
that of course is what everybody knows
him for and the newspapers in the last
couple of months have been full of
anniversary stories of the jungle which
came out well it was published in late
February of 1906 and it was much in the
news for all of that spring and as we
know was instrumental in getting the
Pure Food and Drug legislation passed in
June of 1906 I have an anecdote that I
picked up from a fellow writer of
Sinclair's who described him arriving in
Chicago in nineteen
for in November where he spent six weeks
doing research and I think this this
anecdote gives a little bit of the
flavor of the man earnest Poole was the
name of the writer he said in breezed a
lad and a wide-brimmed hat with a loose
flowing tie and a wonderful warm
expensive smile hello i'm upton sinclair
he said and I've come here to write the
Uncle Tom's Cabin of the labor movement
now how's that for hood spot
ambition a young twenty four years old
and he thinks he's going to compare
himself with Harriet Beecher Stowe's
novel that Abraham Lincoln said started
the Civil War but Sinclair was always a
man of enormous energy and conviction
and ego as well know what Sinclair meant
by that was that the Civil War had been
fought over chattel slavery as it was
called then that battle was over the new
battle at the end of the 19th century in
the beginning of the 20th was the battle
between it was a class warfare between
labor and capital
Sinclair hope to see that resolved
without resort to violence but as you
know there had already been a good deal
of violence at this period the Haymarket
riots and so on Sinclair meant to write
a book that would arouse the sentiments
of his readers who were accustomed to
reading the the other big book the year
his his book was published was Rebecca
of Sunnybrook Sunnybrook farm so this is
a little different and he was hoping to
reach some of those same readers who
were turned on by Rebecca and get them
to have a kind of sympathy for the
plight of the workers in this country he
didn't really intend to write an expose
of the meatpacking industry he only has
about 30 pages of that long novel maybe
300 pages that are devoted to those
famous and disgusting pictures of rats
running over the meat and worse but it
was the appeal to their stomachs that
most readers
bonded to rather than the appeal to
their sympathies for downtrodden foreign
workers Sinclair famously said I aim for
the public's heart and I hit it in the
stomach by mistake that incidentally
checked my old Bartlett's quotations I
don't know how old it is but it's fairly
old but that's the only quote in
Bartlett's for Upton Sinclair and he
said a lot of other quotable things as
well well whatever Sinclair's intent he
won worldwide fame and riches which he
didn't turn down though he was a
socialist with the jungle and one of his
early fans who wrote a huge long review
of it in England was the young military
officer and journalist named Winston
Churchill and Churchill praised Sinclair
to the skies he said he was like a
general marshaling his forces in the
attack and he said he was a young man of
very great gifts and this was indeed
high praise the only thing that
Churchill drew the line at was
Sinclair's advocacy of socialism which
he said missed the point another admirer
although for different reasons was
President Theodore Roosevelt to whom
Sinclair sent a copy and his publicist
sent a copy and a lot of readers around
the country sent letters to Roosevelt
estimated at about a hundred a day
according to Sinclair asking him why he
wasn't paying attention to the
conditions that Sinclair had described
in this novel Roosevelt invited Sinclair
to the White House in the first week of
April they had a very cordial luncheon
that Sinclair recorded afterwards
however the cordiality wore off because
Sinclair became persuaded that Roosevelt
was not pushing Congress hard enough to
get the legislation through it was
bottled up in committees and all the
rest meat packers Lobby was doing what
it could to stall the legislation so
Sinclair
got ahold of a report that was also
being held up by Roosevelt because he
didn't want to release it it was too
damaging to the meatpacking industry
which I didn't realize until I got into
the research on this was the largest
industry in the country at this time I'd
serve a surprise by you think mining or
steel or something would be larger but
meatpacking the food industry and the
meatpacking industry is the largest in
the country and one of the largest in
the world so Roosevelt didn't want to
destroy the economy he wanted to control
the Packers in some way Sinclair thought
that he wasn't doing enough he he got a
hold of the an oral version of this
report from two of the commissioners
involved and late in the night and one
Sunday in April he went to the New York
Times with a suitcase full of materials
including this report and he leaked it I
don't know if he's her first leaker to
the New York Times but I was very
interested in what mr. sills burger had
to say this morning about the Pentagon
Papers and sure enough the leaking of
these documents and other material that
Sinclair had did light a fire under the
Congress did get the legislation sprung
loose and Sinclair can be credited I
think with at least moving it along
getting it off the back burner Roosevelt
when he signed the legislation on June
30th almost exactly a hundred years ago
didn't mention Sinclair in his he
mentioned Breckenridge and a lot of
other people but he didn't mention
Sinclair and later on he complained
rather go Sybaris Lee about Sinclair
said it embarrassed him a lot with his
you know precipitous behavior he even
said he thought he was a crackpot
Sinclair said that's okay he had the
greatest public relations man in the
country working for him and he was happy
he went on after that to a career of
some length in California he moved there
in 1916 with his second wife and he
wrote a number of books attacking
American journalism he wrote a book
called the brass check which some of you
might know I'll explain the title if you
want and during the question and answer
period
you attacked religion you wrote a book
called the prophets of religion PR o fi
TS you can see why this man would have
had trouble later on running for
governor but he did in 1933 accept the
invitation of the local Democratic Party
in Southern California to become their
nominee for governor and he left the
Socialist Party which he'd been a member
of for more than 25 years without a
thought and said okay I'm a Democrat he
had every intention as he said later of
infusing the Democratic Party with his
socialist platform and because of that
and because he was candid about it when
he did win the nomination for the
Democratic Party over the primary of
opposition then the opponents and the
Republican Party got really serious and
the they hammered him pretty hard a lot
has been written about that half-a-dozen
doctoral dissertations and so on
one of the things I think that is
important about Sinclair the reason why
he was asked to run was that he had this
terrific name recognition there's a
funny story about a New York Herald
Tribune reporter who supposedly was at
in the middle of a Gobi Desert and he
asked some Mongolian sheep herder what
is whose favorite writers were I don't
know whether to believe this but the guy
said oh Dostoyevsky and Sinclair so
there you had that kind of name
recognition that kind of instant would
call celebrity that was you know did
attract attention did attract votes he
supported himself for his candidacy by
writing a little book that he called I
governor of California and how I ended
poverty which was set in the future and
and then he he expanded that a little
bit later he said and how I am ending
poverty and civilization not just in
California so he had grand ambitions but
the thing is he had the kind
presence and the kind of energy to
almost carry these off now what kept him
from winning of course was the fact that
he'd managed as Debbie first said the
other day in her comments about about my
biography she said Sinclair seemed to
manage to offend every every conceivable
interest group he was an equal
opportunity offender and among these
groups that he offended particularly
appropriate here for Chautauqua were
sorry my papers are blowing around here
the Methodists of America who he said
were evil the Boy Scouts and we said
we're proto fascists he even insulted
the people of San Francisco he said they
had the morals of a horse trader so it
didn't take long for Sinclair to find
himself in deep trouble because these
boxed quotes were appearing on the front
page of the los angeles time every day
or he also said the Elks were primitive
lowbrows marriage was legalized
prostitution bankers were legalized
counterfeiters Presbyterians were
children of hell I always suspected that
about those Presbyterians right I was
one Sinclair protested that these
remarks were taken out of context which
is what everyone always says but they in
fact were from various things that he
had written some of them in fact were
3040 years old
nevertheless there were other reasons
perhaps why the voters might have been a
little uneasy about electing Sinclair
for example I noticed mr. Saltzburg er
this morning said that a robust
contentious and conscientious news media
are necessary in this country well
Sinclair had been fighting with the
newspapers which was all the media was
then for years ever since he had a messy
divorce which was splashed all over the
front pages
and he was blackballed by the California
Press not blackballed but isolated they
didn't say anything about him that
wasn't bad so he said his way of solving
the problem of the press would be when
he took over that they would receive no
advertising subsidies from the state
which would now own all the businesses
are the major businesses and they would
be run by governing boards and the
governing boards would include the
employees of the newspaper which
probably isn't so bad
but this might give especially this
audience and pause it does me to
appointed college professors you imagine
that plus one other member appointed by
the governor and radio stations would be
quote socialized and the trash would be
cut out of their programs
now all the English teachers in this
crowd will recognize the passive voice
in these constructions and careful
readers did to who was going to be in
charge of this show once Sinclair was in
Sacramento it sounds like a kind of
Plato platonic Republic where the
philosopher king will be Sinclair
himself and here's a wonderful example
of that Sinclair had an idea for what he
called land colonies and much of this of
course made good sense in the middle of
the depression because the problem was
that there was overproduction and you
know under consumption and it just was
kind of crazy crazy business he was
charged at one point for having the
brains of a pigeon because he complained
about about the lack of common sense and
economic policy but he said that he
didn't know much about pigeon anatomy
but he did know the pigeons never went
hungry when there was corn on the ground
and cherries and the trees for them to
eat and that was the case in California
but less sensibly he proposed also that
there would be land colonies which sound
a little bit like the re-education camps
that the Communists there's
fond of here's the quote every land
colony will become a cultural center
with a branch library a motion picture
theater and this one a lecture hall
where we can explain the principles of
cooperation it sounds a little scary
Sinclair didn't win the election but he
came fairly close he got about 38% of
the vote and another progressive
candidate got about 25 so combined it
was shown that there was a nap there was
a hunger for change in the liberal
direction in California in the mid 1930s
and he's usually credited with credited
by political scientists with having
engendered this to a large degree this
is no small accomplishment for a you
know a humble scribbler it really is a
mammoth accomplishment but it's just as
well that he didn't win because even if
he had his programs would have been
bottled up on a conservative legislature
nothing would have happened more happens
by virtue of his many disciples like
Jerry Voorhees who you may remember as
Richard Nixon's first victim in 1946
when Nixon ran for Congress and beat
Jerry Voorhees Voorhees was a volunteer
in Sinclair's epic campaign for governor
and there were many like him
the third major phase of Sinclair's life
and I'll just do this very briefly
begins a few years later Sinclair was
worried like everyone else in this
period about the rise of fascism he was
purged in he said he ran for governor in
part because he hoped to preclude it
happening in California his sometime
friend and younger her namesake Sinclair
Lewis had written a novel that you might
remember it it can't happen here and of
course there was Philip Roth's
novel a few years ago the plot against
America premise taun the idea that
fascism could happen in this country so
Claire was worried about this after he
lost the election he withdrew from
public
life in essence his wife was ill and he
essentially decided to become purely a
writer so he started on us on a novel he
didn't know it would be a series at the
time called World's End which was
published in 1940 and the hero of this
novel is Lani Budd a young talented man
born in 1900 with a century who is of
his parentage is peculiar his mother is
a beautiful American model living and in
France and his father is wealthy arms
manufacturer so you can see the plot
developing already Lani grows up in
France he's introduced to the reader as
he and his English and his German friend
more plot are watching a performance of
an opera and Dresden by the end of the
novel and he's working as an interpreter
during the peace negotiations in Paris
he has many adventures many of them
quite improbable but nevertheless
fascinating in-between he meets all
kinds of important people like Clemens
oh and Lloyd George and and my favorite
the mysterious Turkish Cypriot arms
manufacturer or arms dealer Basil's out
her off fantastic character now Sinclair
vowed to avoid socialist proselytizing
in these books and he by and large
succeeded to the point where his own son
and some of his other fans complained
that he treated the arms dealer the
senior bud too kindly and Sinclair of
course responded that he was just trying
to avoid writing propaganda what he was
doing was the same thing that his friend
George Bernard Shaw had done and major
Barbara when he gives Sir Andrew
Undershaft
you remember the arms dealer in that
play he gives him the best lines just as
he Milton gives Satan the best lines and
Paradise Lost that's how you engage a
reader you make a you make a wonderfully
attractive bad guy and that's what
Lanny's father was so this was something
that Sinclair had not done before he'd
always been as the villains were always
kind of cardboard up to this point now
he was really writing something that
approximated serious fiction and in 1943
he was rewarded for this by getting a
peel and surprise for dragon's teeth
which was his novel about the rise of
Hitler he'd taken Lani all the way
through World War one and the Depression
and into World War two where he's a kind
of he becomes a spy for Roosevelt has
conversations with FDR and the White
House in his bedroom
FDR says things like now Lani tell me
more about Hitler and and you can read
through this without laughing because
Sinclair creates this wonderfully
plausible kind of world by the time he
finished his last lanny bud novel in
1953 he was 75 years old you would think
that it might be time to you know call
it a day but he didn't he went on over
the next years to write a reminiscence
about his friend Albert Einstein he
exchanged letters with Carl Jung about
religion and he wrote a play about the
great Roman orator Cicero that he had
some correspondence with Albert Camus of
all people and Camus liked Sinclair's
play about Cicero so much he said I'm
going to stage this for you and then
Camus had the bad grace to get killed in
an automobile accident and it never
happened but it was very close so I just
loved the idea that Albert Camus would
stage a play by by Upton Sinclair about
Cicero in 1967 he met his last famous
person Lyndon Johnson who invited him to
the White House for the signing of an
updated Meat Inspection Act and at that
time this was his third president
because he'd already met FDR during the
campaign for governor his third
president his final recognition by the
White House that he had something to do
with this momentous legislation in 1906
Ralph Nader was there and later said in
his typically modest form
two generations of consumerism have met
there is a lot more to Sinclair's life
than I have time to tell but I wanted to
just summarize what he did first as a
very young man he wrote a book that
transformed the landscape of the way we
eat our food I think that's no small
accomplishment second in his middle
years he did what Teddy Roosevelt was
always advising people to do back in the
1890s saying get into the arena
don't sit off on the side and complain
the same kind of thing we've been
hearing here a week how do we get
involved
well Sinclair got seriously involved by
running for governor and third at a time
in his life when most people are
retiring or thinking about retiring he
launches himself on a whole new career
as this really very good historical
novelist and writes eleven of them and
they're all long and they're all
interesting I want to close by noting
the appropriateness of a Victorian poem
by Alfred Lord Tennyson that I'm sure
many of you know it's important to
remember that Sinclair was a Victorian
and the Victorians had two key notions
that guided them they were work and duty
the work and duty and for Sinclair the
key thing in every anybody's life but
especially his was finding out what your
what your duty was and then working at
it hard and he said in an
autobiographical novel in 1911 that he
liked Ulysses for the way it's for its
definition of the heroic life as one of
striving against great difficulties for
the good of all and Tennyson's lines I
think apply also to Sinclair because he
has Ulysses say Tennyson doesn't much
have I seen and known cities of men and
manners climates councils government's
myself not least but honoured of them
all
Sinclair came fairly close to achieving
something like that as an entirely
private person which we can talk about
maybe during the question and answer
period and yet Ulysses knows as Sinclair
seems to have known and I our favorite
lines I think for many of us how dull it
is to pause to make an end to rust
unburn --is-- not to shine in use as
though to breathe her life well maybe we
could let these be the final final words
on that energetic and difficult and very
productive American Upton Sinclair that
he did live a life of often heroic
striving and on his own terms and that
he's shown in use thank you very much
[Applause]
port oh okay I've read that Upton
Sinclair really didn't expect to win the
governorship of California and he was in
it mostly to to simply promulgate his
views and that when asked what his first
act would be when he was elected he
would say I'd ask for a recount did he
really say that oh I think he did one of
Sinclair's handicaps as well as his
advantages was that he used to joke a
lot about his about his candidacy and he
was that was attractive because you knew
that Sinclair always spoke what he was
thinking but they could get him in
trouble and that was used against him
during the campaign of course but no he
he was he was candid about his chances
which he thought were a very slight
because in as a socialist he had won
only maybe 60,000 votes but now he won
almost 900,000 so he had a much better
chance I think than he initially thought
he would have he didn't know he'd be
such a good candidate it's part of it he
worried about his writings on higher
education and basic education the coup
step in the Gosling's yeah it could he
wrote two books which were both attacks
on one on higher education called the
goose-step as you said and you can see
what the attitude would have been from
the title and the other the Gosling's
which has a very funny little caricature
of a bunch of little Gosling's marching
across the page
he thought american education was to
doctrinaire to lockstep too rigid too
much based on the German model and he
wanted to do what he could get it
revised his book on the colleges is much
better than the book on the elementary
schools I think but it's still referred
to in the educational literature for
many of his ideas I love one of us I
remember one of his comments about
college professors he said they're all
like they're all like well fed cattle
and their stalls and every once in a
while someone comes along and milks them
it says the
since they're kept and if they step out
of line they get slaughtered for beef
yeah yes did Upton Sinclair never offer
any comments there are judgments
regarding the Arts and Crafts movement
of that period in time Upton Sinclair
had the number of comments about the
Arts and Crafts movement but not so much
about it it was about Elbert Hubbard who
was the Arts and Crafts movement founder
Hilbert Elbert Hubbard as you knows from
dear here in Rochester and he attacked
Sinclair for the jungle in fact he was
hired by the meatpackers to attack
Sinclair and Sinclair and turn attacked
Hubbard called him a worm so that was
his extent of his comments on the arts
and crafts world I've heard a couple of
comments over the last few weeks that
suggested that Upton Sinclair had either
exaggerated or even manufactured some of
the bad conditions in the meatpacking
plant have you had a chance to evaluate
the accuracy of what he wrote about
those institutions having to do with the
accuracy of what Sinclair said in his
book about the meatpackers as I noted
earlier the relative paucity of pages
maybe thirty thirty-five dealing with
the bad conditions are the ones that got
the attention the Publishers Doubleday
and page made him take out a lot of
stuff that they thought was either
unprovable or or too dangerous and some
people think that that's a kind of
expurgated addition what was published
everything that remained in it with one
notable exception had corroborating
evidence or or some sort of assurance
that it was if not true pretty close to
being true and that was the one about
the workers falling into the vats and
coming at the other end is nothing but
lard that could never be documented but
there been a lot of studies done on this
you can go on the web today as I did
just last night and you can find
Q's Asians that Sinclair was inaccurate
and a fool for what he had said but the
general thing is I remember a professor
in college explained the difference
between naturalism and realism to me as
the difference between the Main Street
and the alleys and the naturalism is
looking at everything it's in the alleys
and that's what Sinclair was doing he
was looking at the alleys and not the
Main Street he recorded what he saw
there and I think it was accurate I
remember as a youngster in the 40s early
50s reading the Lanny bud series and
they really impressed me it was a very
special insight into a particular era
between World War 1 and World War 2 I
understand that there's a resurgence of
interest in those books I wonder if
they're being republished I know I own
six of them but I'm looking for the
other five do you know that they're
about to be republished or anything
about them there's a an independent
publisher in Florida named Andrew Simon
who has a website and if you go and
google his name you'll come up with a
website and he is reissuing the Lanny
bud novels and I think some other
Sinclair novels as well incidentally
there was a very good article last
summer and the New York Times about by
Julie Salomon about the Lanny bud novels
if you wanted to look that up yeah by
being here this afternoon is the first
introduction this man I if you need more
time to be here could you tell me what
made him so interesting what kind of
formative life did he have yeah I dealt
today mostly with his public life but
his private life was interesting because
he was born to wealth and poverty at the
same time his father was the son of
military people in Virginia and
Sinclair's ancestors on that side
where
fought for the Confederacy and the Navy
and he himself had plants when he grew
up to become a midshipman but his father
was an alcoholic and a Salesman and the
family lived in poverty in Baltimore and
New York from about age his age five
onward at the same time his mother's
family had wealth on its side because
her sister married into a very wealthy
family in Baltimore
so Sinclair spent his youth shuttling
between boarding houses some flea traps
in New York and downtown Baltimore out
to town houses and country houses and
the juxtaposition of the world of
extreme poverty and extreme wealth
struck him as as a paradox that he
couldn't resolve and he said eighty when
he was 85 he said he still couldn't
resolve why this should be so in such a
wealthy country and so he rather
simplistically I think said the problem
must have to do with the economic
structure of the country which is
capitalism and the only way to change
that is socialism so his early
experience was what conditioned him to
his later economic and philosophical
beliefs yes I was a young student in
Budapest Hungary and I was reading Upton
Sinclair many of his books that were not
censored and they were translated and
they were permitted to be read they were
on in all the libraries I just thought
I'd let you know that was in 1955 1954
1956 so just a comment well I'm glad to
see you Yona port even though I spent a
year in Hungary so I that's the only
word I remember means alone I was struck
when I was in Hungary and and later in
Germany by the popularity of Upton
Sinclair and later on that was
reinforced by my my researches he was
always much more popular in Europe than
he was in the United States though he's
popular enough here but Europeans took
him
and the way they read Jack London and
Theodore Dreiser and other writers of
this period as kind of giving them the
inside scoop about what America was
really like and consequently he was
extraordinarily well received Brecht
wrote a play st. Joan of the stockyards
which was based on Sinclair and he was
regarded there as a kind of intellectual
touchstone and all the time I was
researching Sinclair I had the
impression he must have lived there for
years because his knowledge of Europe
seemed to be so profound but in fact he
only was there for about 16 months in
1912 and 13 or 11 12 13 so anyway yes
his the response to him in Europe was
overwhelming and and still is I'm going
to go there this fall I think and teach
a course in Dresden where they they have
a guy who's made his career on Upton
Sinclair yes sir I was wondering did he
ever pay off his campaign debts his run
for governor in full and what kind of
mistakes if you leave the time of his
death he did pay off his campaign debts
which were not that enormous maybe less
than a hundred thousand nothing like
what they would be today but he did do a
kind of cross-country tour speaking to
her and most of that money went to pay
off his debts as for his estate it's a
little unclear late in his life there
was a letter from his son David who was
at that time a physicist and de Neville
stuff and he wrote to his father and
said gee dad I understand you just left
all your estate to the United Auto
Workers how about your family and
Sinclair wrote back and you said well
okay maybe you have a point so whatever
a state there was and it's it's not
clear it wasn't large because Sinclair
although he made a lot of money in the
1940s with his lanny bud novels most of
that dribbled away or was spent and
maintaining his wife's health care in
the 50s and into the early 60s so there
wasn't a large estate I think we're at
the end
thank you very much Anthony Arthur
author of radical innocent Upton
Sinclair for more information visit
Anthony Arthur dotnet